Russian President Vladimir Putin
made his first public appearance
on the global stage
since that Wagner rebellion
late last month.
Vladimir Putin appearing alongside
other international leaders,
including Chinese
President Xi Jinping,
in a virtual summit.
CNN's Will
Ripley is covering this story
from Taiwan.
So, Will,
what was the Russian president's message
it was
it was the optics of the whole thing
that was particularly interesting
to see Putin and Xi.
These two,
you know, no limits partners
at a time that Putin's power
is very much in question
after what happened in late
June with the Wagner group.
And then, of course, President Xi,
who is arguably stronger
than ever,
really assuming
his role of the leader
of the authoritarian bloc,
if you will, which also includes
Belarus and Iran, would join
this Shanghai
cooperation organization meeting,
which was hosted online
by the Indian prime minister.
And so Putin, in his message, talked
about deeper
security cooperation
between the members of this organization,
and he insisted that Moscow
would stand up against
what he called
illegitimate sanctions
over his unprovoked invasion of Ukraine.
Listen,
But I
see the Russian people
are consolidated as never before.
The solidarity
and high responsibility
for the fate of the Fatherland
was clearly demonstrated
by Russian political circles
and the entire society
by coming out
as a united front
against the attempted armed rebellion
revolution
Obviously, Putin there
with a lot of friendly leaders.
This is this is
this was not a contentious
group of people
that were going to try to go after him
or embarrass him in this first
multilateral international
forum appearance
since those armed mercenaries
threatened to march on Moscow.
But he did express appreciation
to the leaders for their support,
including China's Xi Jinping Xi.
For his part,
he called out kind of in an indirect way.
Alex, the United States
saying that
the world should reject what he called
protectionism and decoupling.
This is a reference,
of course, to the United States
efforts to try to reduce
trade and investment
with China, particularly
in sensitive areas
such as technology, which the U.S.
has long feared is being
used by the Chinese military.
All right, Will Ripley in Taipei,
thank you very much.
Let's go straight to our experts
to break all this down.
Our military analyst,
the retired Lieutenant General
Mark Hertling, and Jill Dougherty,
who, of course, is a CNN contributor
on Russian affairs.
Thank you
both for joining me
on this Fourth of July.
Jill, I want to start with you.
How important
is it
right now
for Putin to appear on this global stage
surrounded by big global leaders
like those of China and India?
Oh, I think it's crucial
because after all, you know, a
week or so ago, you had a rebellion
with troops
or fighters on their way to Moscow.
That undermines
Putin's image
not only domestically,
but internationally.
And a lot of these countries
that have supported him
must be asking
the question,
is he really still in charge?
Is he still,
you know,
Vladimir Putin, who we supported
said or
a lot of questioning behind the scenes
and he absolutely had to get out there.
He's been out domestically
and now internationally.
General Hertling,
we just
heard today
that the NATO's secretary
general, Jens Stoltenberg,
his term has been extended
by another year.
What do you think
allies need to accomplish
in this upcoming NATO's summit in Vilnius
as it pertains to Ukraine?
Yeah, well, first of all, access
a great point,
because Secretary
Sullivan said
the mayor has selflessly done this.
He wanted to retire long ago.
He stayed on
because he realizes
that NATO's is at war in all effects.
So what he will
accomplish is a continual
coordination
of the alliance to support Ukraine.
It's an important point.
He is very selfless
and doing it, as I just said,
and it's a good thing.
There will be several things
that he will accomplish.
Being familiar with the situation
and certainly linked with
Defense Minister Reznik call from Ukraine
and certainly Defense Minister
or minister of defense
excuse me, Secretary of Defense
Austin and Secretary of State Blinken
from the United States.
There
are, of course, Jill
real divisions among NATO's leaders
about how when, if Ukraine should join
the Naito Alliance.
How much do you think NATO's is weighing
Russia's opposition to the expansion
of NATO's
and how Putin may respond to that?
Oh, I think less than ever.
I mean, that used to be the debate.
You know, will this anger Putin?
There's a lot of the reverse feeling now.
I mean, what you hear from the allies,
especially the ones that are saying
the Baltics
and Poland, etc.,
are saying we don't care
what Putin thinks.
In fact,
if we continue to think about why Putin
what Putin thinks
we will weaken our own defense.
So it's really full steam ahead.
The problem,
I think,
is the United States
and some other countries are a little bit
more careful about it.
And the trick would be trying
to figure out
what can you give Ukraine
to give them hope
that there will be something
in the future
without committing Entirely.
That's really difficult balance
that that's what they'll be working.
And of course, so much has
been given
to Ukraine
ahead of this counteroffensive,
both in terms of training
and in terms of weaponry.
General Hertling,
are you seeing signs that
that Ukraine is gaining momentum
in this counteroffensive?
They have taken,
I think some
14, 15 square miles,
but really have yet to punch through.
How much progress
do you think they're making?
I am seeing momentum, Alex,
and it's a great question
because there's a lot of Western analysts
who suggest that Ukraine
is not going fast enough.
One of the things I'd point out
is Ukraine is now the third largest army
in Europe.
Behind Russia and Turkey,
that they were at one point
about the 11th largest army in Europe.
So we're talking about the capability
of the Ukrainian
armed forces
to become even stronger on a daily basis.
And what I see is they are conducting
this operation in a very
very correct manner.
They're probing.
They're continuing
to look for ways to assault.
They're keeping their reserves there.
Nine brigades
that have been trained
in the rest in the West
excuse me, in reserve
so they can conduct the operation
once they find the weak spots
in the Russian lines.
It's going to be a very tough fight
in the next six to eight weeks.
But I think Ukraine is going to succeed
in what they're doing.
You know,
a very tough fight
could take quite some time.
Jill Dougherty,
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling,
thank you both for joining me.
A very happy fourth of July to you both
and to you. Thank you.